This commenter wanted to say,
my husband doesn't make enough as an electrician because, um,
I do so much work during the day, in my day,
in the lives. The thing about being a homemaker,
about being a chadwife, is that you are going to be doing work.
That's not the soft life.
It's not avoiding work.
Work is a good thing.
It's been ordained by god.
I think it's a common misconception that if you stay home,
you just get to sit around all day and just do nothing and watch TV.
And that's just not true to some people do that, sure,
but that's not being a good steward of your home.
Being a traditional wife,
a homemaker, is extremely hard work.
It is a lot of long hours into your home,
into your family,
into your children.
But I seriously would not have it any other way.
It is much better than going outside of the home for me
and working a 9 to five.
Um, I get to decide what goes on in my day.
I get to decide what I wanna do,
minus the, the regular housekeep of the home.
But yeah, it's still work, and it's important work.
So if you are in this position,
just know your work is important.
The Lord sees you even though society might not.
It is extremely important work,
so keep at it.
Keep doing it.
You go.
Being a traditional wife,
a homemaker, is extremely hard work.
It is a lot of long hours into your home,
into your family,
into your children.
But I seriously would not have it any other way.
It is much better than going outside of the home for me
and working a 9 to five.
Um, I get to decide what goes on in my day.
I get to decide what I wanna do.
Minus the, the regular housekeep of the home.
But yeah, it's still work and it's important work.
So if you are in this position,
just know your work is important.
The Lord sees you even though society might not.
It is extremely important work,
so keep at it,
keep doing it.
You go your homemaker,
traditional wife, and you stay home and you might feel like,
oh, my goodness,
this work is just so much.
I don't know how I'm gonna do it.
Just know that the Lord sees your efforts,
even though society might not see your efforts.
The Lord sees you working day in and day out for your family.
So keep up the good work,
do everything,
eyes onto the Lord, and be joyful and cheerful in the work of the home.